foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships I'm your host Jade
warshaw and I am joined today by my
friend Rachel Cruz so good to be here
with you Jay it's great it's so good
we're taking your calls today we're
talking about your life your money hey
we're both moms so if we have any moms
that want to call in uh with any
questions the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
here for you America all right let's go
to the phone lines we got Benjamin in
San Antonio Texas what's going on
Benjamin
Hey so uh why can I uh we are we just
started baby step two and we are also
expecting our first baby oh
congratulations
so the question is you know um
my job I make pretty good money but I
don't make it I'm a chauffeur and so I'm
just not exactly an independent
contractor but I don't get vacation and
I don't get any kind of pay time off
okay so the question is when the baby
comes I wanted to take a week off to
help with the wife because those first
time first kid and any kind of
complications we don't know what's going
to happen right and the baby's born
um but in order to take a week off I
have to set aside enough money to cover
the income I'm going to lose which
basically means pausing that that
snowball for the next six to eight weeks
up to you know depending on because my
income changes every month depending on
commissions you know what I get but the
simple question is is that a good idea
yeah I mean when it comes to the baby
steps when it comes to the debt snowball
we do you know recommend pausing until
baby comes we call that stork mode and
it's kind of just making sure we have as
much money saved up as possible Right
Rachel for anything that might happen
with the baby I mean God willing your
baby's gonna come it's going to be
healthy Beautiful Everything perfect but
it is nice to have that money saved up
um for anything that might come up with
Hospital charges and in this case if you
need to stay home for an extra week or
whatever that time is now is the time
for you guys to start stacking that
money up and so if you're pausing the
debt snowball or pausing whatever baby
step that you're on for that time that's
totally fine yeah absolutely and
Benjamin we would recommend that for you
guys to pause that even if you weren't
taking time off work or even if you were
on a salary still making money
um so yeah for anyone listening that's
exactly right we pause the debt snowball
save up cash while you're waiting on
baby once baby and mom comes home that's
great press play use all that money
that's saved if you haven't even you
didn't need it and throw it at the debt
so for you your case Benjamin then
that's great I would set aside a
specific amount of money
um for that week since you're going to
take that off and you guys kind of plan
around that but uh yeah you're doing it
exactly right how does that sound
Benjamin
that sounds that sounds good awesome
congratulations hopefully as well very
very cool that's a really good call out
Rachel I think a lot of times people
forget that oh like when that's
happening you can pause and take that
quick break yeah and we say that too
even with big Life Changes right if
you're if you know you're going to be
relocating uh or moving jobs and it's
like yeah we need some to have some cash
for moving expenses right if you know
that there's a big life change coming
that is a time that we say hey if you
need to pause save up some money and
even for cars you know we talk to people
and their car breaks down it's not worth
anything it it's you know they they have
to pay more to get it fixed instead
they're like oh my gosh what do I do
then we're like okay pause and make sure
those four walls are covered so so again
the gazelle intensity is so important
but also planning for those big life
events that are going to happen through
the baby step process even hell for yes
Health if something comes up with your
major you know major illness you're not
able to work so it's really good to call
out those times where it is all right
where we're not going to yell at you as
a matter of fact we're going to cheer
you on if you do pause the baby steps
let's take another call we've got Devon
am I saying that right Devon in
Jacksonville
that's Devin Devin you know I had to put
a little Swag On It Kevin I'm sorry
about that okay
I was wondering too Devon it's just
Devin how can we help you Jeff how can
we help all right so uh so I'm in the uh
military and I just got orders uh to go
out across the country to Washington
State and my orders right now will keep
me there for at least two and a half
years and my wife and I are wondering if
it kind of what's a break even or
they're worth it to uh rent versus buy a
house yeah it's a great question well
first thanks for your service
um for you and your wife because that's
a that's a huge sacrifice so thank you
for that
um yeah if you're relocating especially
people in the military that are moving
so much we don't recommend buying so
renting is great because what you know
as we experience right now and even in
the last 18 24 months how crazy real
estate has been the market has been so
those ups and downs are still we're
still feeling that and so we don't want
you caught up buying high and then if
something happens and you're got you
have to sell for less or you know
whatever it is so five years or more is
where I feel comfortable with someone
purchasing a home and being in it uh
it's enough time to kind of ride at the
market but if you're going to just be
there two and a half years uh Devin yeah
I would I would just rent I would too
what do you think about that Devin how
does that how does that hit you
so I've we bought a house uh here in
Jacksonville and we've been in it for
just over five years and we got it paid
off fully paid off oh wow
congratulations that's kind of thank you
that's kind of where we were at um
that's kind of uh
what we were thinking is you know you
buy the house and if you I mean you can
break even on it and then there's still
money ahead of renting because running's
kind of like a 100 interest Loan in my
opinion yeah I understand but also you
know buying a home it's the one of the
largest assets that majority of people
buy and so I want you to just be
thinking through to make sure okay are
we going to get out better on the other
end and again it's just it's just the
fact that the time frame is so short uh
is where is where that comes into play
or will you guys be moving back to
Jacksonville after you go to Washington
do you think
there's a really good chance uh that I
could visit the community that I'm in is
kind of based out of there but there's
no guarantee okay okay with that paid
off home that you have I mean when it's
time to move if you guys sell it you can
keep that money High interest savings
account and just continue to grow that
nest egg and then when you get someplace
stable you're gonna have a lot of money
to work with and probably be able to buy
something again totally in cash I mean
that's exciting to me what do you think
about that
sounds good to me all right Devin thanks
for your call you know that's a really
good point
um a lot of people you know they're not
really sure what the parameters are
around saving up for a house and then
how long do you keep the house and if
you're moving should you sell the house
or can you rent out the house I feel
like that's a really good talking yeah
we talk about that a lot um yeah we
never recommend being a long distance
landlord oh gosh that sounds like the
worst I know it's a it's a it's a
headache I mean it really is and so for
some people
um Devin didn't say this but in his case
you know we've heard things like this of
like okay I'll keep my house yeah rent
it out and all of it and it ends up it
just ends up being a mess and how can
you oversee that if you're I mean he's
literally across the country and not
saying that he was going to do this but
a lot of people might think oh I'm
coming back to the house later let's
rent it out but you really can't manage
your property from across the country no
yeah you'd be probably paying a property
manager and all that and it's just it's
just the hassle and so we always say
yeah just kind of have that clean slate
and then you'll have the cash that's
right uh from the equity if it's not
fully paid paid off or all of it if it
is paid off and that's your money and
you may make a different decision with
that amount of money you know if you had
it and to say hey Jade would you go buy
this go buy a house in Oklahoma City
with this money right now absolutely not
no probably not so that's how you have
to think about it too yeah it's exciting
he can keep that money if he's gonna
keep it more than five years he could
invest it for a while and let it grow
anymore even more if he's planning on
using it for less than five years then
he should keep it in a high yield
savings account so that's what we would
do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show hey
give us a call today the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll take questions about whatever
it is you guys want to talk about we
will talk about that on the air live
with you so we're going to take a call
now we're going to go to John in
McClellan Texas what's going on John
mccalyn Texas hi
hi um so my question is so I'm basically
I'm kind of all over the place here
um so I have I'm almost done paying off
my credit card debt because I'm I'm 22
so I just got my credit cards I have
like a 200 debt so I'm gonna pay that
down okay and actually a lot of that's
going to be returned because I returned
some items so I was just wondering and I
have 200 in savings but I was just
wondering like where do I go from here
like to just really build like to build
upon that and like when do I start
investing and I actually had Investments
but I sold them because I have to get an
emergency fund first before I invest
at all so just where do I go from here
and also I am on SSI so just so you know
I can't really save in a savings account
because if I saved too much in a savings
account they'll take that away and I'll
lose my health insurance so what do I
you know what do I do and I do make well
19 321 a year and
um my jobs are like through cohorts so
I'm not actually employed by the company
but I get paid through Texas Workforce
so it's like a program so that's kind of
like my uh Financial stuff so if you
could just help me lead me in the right
direction cool cool so let's go back to
this debt real quick so the is the only
debt that 200 in credit cards or is
there more
um well no IO so it's 216 in credit
cards and then 148 to just uh some a
series of a friend of mine okay so 348
total
yes but uh but as I mentioned 133 of the
credit card debts didn't go off because
I made a return so that's great it would
be like 80 in credit cards yeah okay
great that's great John I mean is there
is and there's no car loans no student
loans no um no no anything no no I live
in I live at home all the all those
things yeah very good well you're in a
you're in a great spot John I feel very
encouraged by this because you're going
to be able to take care of this debt
really quickly
um because that is what we talk about
getting a thousand dollar emergency fund
do you have any savings besides the 200
because you said you cashed out some
Investments
you know no other savings was like 200
about to be 300 here soon but yeah no no
other savings well I have some gold and
stuff in the safe but that's about it or
silver not gold sorry okay did you have
Investments though that you said you
you cashed out
yeah I cashed out um yeah I sold them uh
so how much cash did you get from those
116 oh okay that that that's why it's
that that's part of the 200. and and the
golden the gold and silver did you say
gold and silver or just gold no just
just so just no just silver I made a
mistake I wish I had gold no well how
much how what's the value of that
uh I think it's just like 20 bucks
because it's just a a silver dollar oh
oh okay okay so hold on to that keep it
someplace real keep it in your top sock
drawer that's right so let's just walk
through these baby steps just so you
understand what the path is going
forward because as of right now uh you
know Rachel just talked about baby step
one and you're just gonna start saving
for that thousand dollars to get it
saved right and then from there we're
gonna pay off this little bit of credit
card debt that you have you're gonna be
able to hopefully you can cash flow all
of this with one like payment cycle
which I think you can and then from
there it's baby step three we want to
get three to six months saved up in your
case three months might do it
um if you're looking to move out anytime
soon maybe make it a little bit more so
you have a little bit more to jump off
into living on your own when the time
comes and then from there baby step four
we're putting away 15 into retirement
and I think for now that's a good place
for you to kind of land and just kind of
get your bearings and those first four
baby steps uh how does that sound
that sounds that sounds good yeah hey
John tell me about your job I was a
little bit confused will you walk me
through what your plan is you're 22
you're living at home
um you're making 19 000 a year what's
what's your what's your aspirations when
it comes to careers
so I want to I'm gonna go to college in
the summer
um I want to major in business and major
in computer science okay great good for
you how are you going to pay for that
um so because of my uh disability
because I am legally blind so because of
that wow yeah a lot a lot of it paid by
a Texas Workforce yeah
John great job oh my gosh yeah
absolutely well you're that's incredible
absolutely incredible
um yeah so we are cheering you on to get
scholarships and to be able to get that
degree and make some big income coming
in um you know even more than what
you're making now uh and start saving
and doing all this and John the one of
the best things going for you number one
is that you're you care yep um there's
such a level of personal responsibility
you can hear from him yes and he wants
to do this well and I think you're at a
really good spot John to do this really
well
um like Jade was saying you know even
with your numbers I'm like oh you could
get that cleaned up you know so quickly
um and that's exciting for me on this
end you're on to encourage you in that
because I think you're going to be able
to get through these baby steps and uh
and kudos to YouTube John let me just
say that that 22 years old yeah oh he's
not letting anything hold him back no
he's not I love that John thanks for
calling in no excuses let's take another
call we got Adam in Gillette Wyoming
what's going on Adam how can we help
uh yeah I just had a quick question
about the baby steps so my wife and I
are we're in baby step two
um and I'm looking at doing a career
change from being a teacher to being an
administrator
and for that we would end up having to
move so I've already interviewed for the
administrator position and we would end
up having to move about three and a half
hours away okay
um if I were to get it so I was just
curious do I need to if I should be
looking to stop baby set two or put it
on hold for a while if that offer comes
down the pipe
um to save up and pay for the move or do
we just kind of keep going at it and
then just kind of hope to use the equity
from our house on the move or yeah Adam
that's a really good question if I were
you and this is also what we teach again
another time to pause the baby steps and
make sure that you can stack up money
and prepare for the move because you're
going to want to use whatever Equity
from the home to roll into your next
home purchase and can I just tell you
from experience it is expensive to move
so stack up as much money as you can
because there's always I mean really sit
down with your wife and start budgeting
out all of the costs anything thing that
you can possibly foresee now is a good
time to start pricing out the different
Moving and Storage matter of fact it's a
good time to take a look at PODS moving
and storage you know and see what they
have I know they've got really great
promos offered all the time
um so yeah definitely pause the baby
steps stack up that money and then you
know yeah see how it goes from there
yeah and I would get
um yeah definitely I would check out
pods and if there's other things other
companies you're willing to look at get
get kind of a roundabout you know
estimates of what you think it's gonna
what the move is going to take and then
I would make that my next goal to have
that money saved so that when the time
comes to move it's like hey that money's
there for it and Adam you guys may even
surpass that amount of money and if you
do then you guys can press play on baby
step two and keep knocking out that debt
but I do want you to have some money
stacked away to be able to cash flow
that move so yeah I would go and look at
some estimates and kind of have that
number in your head you and your wife
and save up to that and then beyond that
continue down baby step two I love that
what do you think Adam
that sounds that sounds good that's
actually what I was thinking I was kind
of thinking it was like like you guys
teach when you're having a kid it would
be a time to stack it up but I just
wasn't 100 sure yeah on how we should do
it I mean we're only three months into
the baby steps so it's kind of it's new
yeah and the hard thing is is that for
so many people especially if you guys
are on baby step two and you're kind of
in it and you're feeling the progress
It's like oh deposit sometimes it's like
you can't you don't want to lose the
momentum so there's a little bit of me
that's always like man don't pause it
but you want to be wise you know you
don't want to be caught to be like oh my
gosh I have this great new job oh my
gosh and I have to move and I have no
cash you know so you want to be wise in
the process but also keep that gazelle
intensity going as you're as you're
saving up for the move absolutely and
that will help too oh man and I I
actually posted a reel on social uh
because we just moved from South Florida
here to Tennessee in September and um
the just just when you think there's no
more cost something else happens and
it's just like oh gosh I didn't think
about that so as much as you can right
every thing out try to prepare because
as I said just when you think it's
finished something else will pop up and
it's like oh my gosh but it's so much
peace when you're prepared for it so yes
I love that you are listening to the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
it's the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz this is
fun Rachel I'm enjoying hosting I know
and we were together last night at The
Building Wealth yes Indianapolis event
sold out totally sold out yes over 2 000
people and it was such a great night it
was so fun and here we are working I
know George camel he's probably home
asleep I mean he's getting that good
sleep Rachel we are we're working hard
we're keeping we're keeping the ship
afloat and can I just say the people of
Indianapolis such great people
today yes I was telling someone earlier
I'm like man I don't know what it is but
they were just kind and wonderful and
yeah so it was fun it was a fun event
I'm excited next week we'll be in Austin
doing the same Building Wealth live
event Rachel are you on that one I'm not
on that one are you I am I believe
you're going out next week yes it is
myself Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman and John
deloney oh Jade I'm sorry I won't be
there for female support
email Guys somebody needs to come get me
because this is gonna be it's gonna be
fun that's so great yeah I'll be in I'll
be in Salt Lake City okay in April with
George Christina Ellis and Dave Ramsey
and then we have Anaheim California
which I think is May 3rd yes does that
sound right yep and so that's gonna be
Dave Ramsey John deloney King Coleman
and Christina Ellis yes so you can get
all your tickets there at those cities
at ramsaysolutions.com
these things are selling like hotcakes
so get get these tickets it's so
exciting all right Rachel there's
something that's been floating around
people have sent it to me in my DMs I
come in this morning to an email from
James Childs our producer guys credit
card debt it is just going bananas okay
it says uh as credit card debt hits an
all-time high all time
just shy of a trillion with the T and
that's just credit card debt Jay that's
not Carlos student loans that's nothing
credit card debt it says in the final
three months of 2022 it's hit an
all-time high delinquencies among
borrowers obviously have accelerated I
mean it makes sense we're taking out
more debt we can't afford the debt and
now we're defaulting on the payments it
says balances grew 61 billion
billion in the fourth quarter from
previous uh from the previous one to 986
billion dollars
wait that is unbelievable it jumped from
61 billion to 986 billion
so much I'm so much sorry I'm really
just taking this in because it's
ridiculous and here it says U.S
household debt jumped to a record
16.90 trillion from October through
December last year the largest quarterly
increase in 20 years as mortgage and
credit card balance is surged amid High
inflation and Rising interest rates all
right and let's just say this because
usually people are talking about the
interest rates you know on mortgages
yeah the interest rates on your credit
cards you guys are going up and here's
the deal and here's why we keep saying
to have that emergency fund in place and
figure out your income minus expenses
need SQL zero living on a zero-based
budget and all that because if you don't
have a plan for your money Jade you know
who has a plan the credit card company
yes they do yes they do and they are
prepared for this you guys they are
ready to be your emergency fund yes that
on top of fees and interests and then
people can't pay the credit card bills
and and it ends up being a massive a
mass massive problem and so that's why
they're dangerous that's why people are
always like you don't just carry one you
know I'm like no play with snakes you're
going to get bit like gonna get bit no
no stay away you guys and and figure out
a way that you are your emergency
friends yes and not the credit card
companies and the banks and I mean with
these interest rates Rachel the average
interest rate now 20 on credit cards on
credit cards 20 that's out of control
and here's the thing here's the the way
my brain works I'm thinking okay if
you're using your credit card to buy
daily things because you're not on a
budget because here's the thing A lot of
people are they do they keep their
credit cards there for emergencies but
then there's that sect of people who's
like okay I'm not really on a budget I'm
not really watching where my money is
going so there's this Gap at the end of
the month or Midway through the month
and I'll just use the credit cards to
float me when I go to the grocery store
or heaven forbid when you go to a
restaurant and eat dinner right and your
your skin can I just you're scanning
your credit card for a meal that's gonna
be gone Rachel in about in about four to
six hours okay so you're literally
flushing money down the drain yes you're
flushing it down the toilet and oh yeah
and here's to get me started and here's
the big thing we were talking about
inflation last night at the event and
all the numbers that are coming out are
saying on average food is up yes 9.8 10
yeah and it feels more than that eggs
are up like 60 or something crazy so I
know there are certain products that are
are up more but here's the video if you
don't have that margin yeah when this
inflation hits that needs to be your
wake-up call to say wow if I have a 10
change in something yes and it is
knocking me out to depend on credit
cards then your whole financial picture
needs to look different you guys and
that's not to shame you that's not to
right to say oh my gosh like you're so
stupid all that no no it is to be able
to say man what I am doing is not
working yeah it's a symptom of something
greater right Rachel that's right that's
exactly right and you know this Jay I
mean we talked about this even last
night again but just the the lifestyle
that we choose to live regardless of
whether there's money in the bank or not
yeah continues continues to be at this
level and you can't just be at that
level if you don't have the money and
the and the credit cards yeah are
filling in that Gap and it's getting
people in so much trouble you guys we
are walking around in such Financial
bondage to have what to have the nice
dinner out to have the purse to and I
would say to have the future food and
all of it but but again if you have a
700 car payment leaving if you have your
student loan payment leaving they have
no money you guys it's a it's the whole
picture we want you to wake up it is the
whole picture and we want you guys free
from that that's why we do this show
because we're like we want to help guide
you and show you there's such a better
way to live with your money and your
your true testimony to that Jade I was
just thinking about that and and I do
want to hit that because I know there
are people listening right now that are
like Jade Rachel yes you're right the
people who are spending credit card
money to buy steak bad bad bad but I'm
just I'm just trying to pay my bills I'm
trying to keep the lights on and I I
hear that because there were there was a
stretch of time uh because Sam and I had
over 20 000 in credit card debt just so
you all know and there was a stretch of
time that we weren't working uh we were
in between jobs and we when I tell you
we had close to zero dollars coming in
and we were using credit cards to try to
like fill in the gaps the worst idea
ever and we thought oh we'll just do
this it's just temporary and then you
know when we get when we get back on our
feet or when we get working again we'll
pay it all off and that is such a
vicious cycle because you're just
creating more debt for the you know
you're creating more debt that you can't
pay because you don't have any money
that's right and the best thing that you
can do when you're in a situation where
money is low right because income is not
enough is to go out and just get more
work and and don't be too far above any
form of work yeah because I think that
there's a can I just be honest I think
some people are like no I'm too good to
work at the mall or I'm too good to
deliver pizzas or I'm too good to take
to drive Uber or whatever it is but
you've got whatever it takes to not take
on debt that is noble and there is so
much dignity and saying I am going to
pay my own bills I am going to make my
own way I am not going to do this with
high interest because let me tell you
something just because you take out High
interest debt does not make you a more
interesting person all right it just
makes you more broke so it there is
dignity to that but I hear the person
who's like man I'm just trying to make
ends meet and if that's you the best
thing I can encourage you to do get on a
budget focus on the four walls and find
any work that you can just because it's
probably just temporary that's right you
just close that Gap up the worst thing
that you can do in a time like that is
depend on credit cards yeah especially
at the tune of 20 interest all right
that's right I know you keep kind of
digging into that hole and it gets
deeper and deeper and the deeper it is
the more time and the more effort on the
other end you're gonna do to climb your
way out that's right so stay keep your
head above water and like you're saying
Jade yes that extra income bringing it
and there's so many side hustles right
now in life yes there is and it's not
going backwards it's actually propelling
you to go forward in life to take
control of your income so you guys you
can do this we hear stories day in and
day out with our jobs of people that are
that decide to make a change and they're
not going to be these stats anymore of
the highest credit card debt that we've
seen yet in history so don't be a stat
either don't be a stat and if you've got
credit card debt working into your debt
snowball list them out smallest to
largest make minimum payments on all of
it and throw any and all extra money at
the smallest debt and move with speed
and intensity to get it paid off this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
thanks for being with us you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm Jade
warshaw your co-host and I'm here with
Rachel Cruz this is a great time hey
guys if you've got calls we want to take
your calls the number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and uh let's take a call Rachel let's
see what Megan is talking about in
Dallas Texas what's going on Megan
hi Jade hi Rachel
um so I just graduated with my Master's
in August however my mother passed away
in June oh I'm so sorry and um yeah I've
been living with him for some time
because I had a problem I've been sober
for seven years uh so I was like living
with them while I was going to school
and now I have
my new job and I'm making like sixty
thousand dollars a year I have a car
payment and I have some credit card debt
I also have fifteen thousand dollars
cash and 27 000 in retirement
um the thing is is like I I feel like
I'm not really intentional with my money
because I still live with my dad
um so I still kind of feel like a
Perpetual 18 year old because I'm like
yeah it's okay I pay my credit cards off
every month but I use my credit card so
much
that it's like I don't save any money so
I was thinking like I probably ought to
just move out to like get more serious
and independent with my money however
part of me doesn't want to lead him
right now because it hasn't even been a
year since my mom passed away
um
what's her passing was it sudden Megan
or was it um
she was she was sick since like 2021
um she was doing really well
and then she went to the hospital and
all this other stuff and she got covered
and then her organ started shutting down
oh my gosh yeah it was like really
really crappy
um so it was kind of fun like me and my
dad both believed that she would get
better
um unfortunately that's not what God had
planned
um but like I just don't know because
like my dad has never lived on his own
he has seven brothers and sisters he
went straight to the Army and then him
and my mom got married while they were
both in the Army so it's like
it's hard because I don't want to just
leave him with no one
you know number one I'm so sorry that
sounds just Unthinkable it's so tough um
navigating a loss like that and you know
I'm just thinking about in in a lot of
situations especially dealing with money
we would tell people not to move quickly
you know take time to grieve and take
time to adjust to this change and I feel
like in the same situation it applies I
don't feel like you need to be in a rush
to do anything like you said it hasn't
even been a year it hasn't been a long
span of time
um
I I'm okay with you doing whatever you
need to do to process this if that's
staying at home a little bit longer
um while you're there I do think it's
important that you think about a plan of
what's going to happen next
yeah you know because I like I got the
every dollar app and I'm like looking at
my spending and I'm like holy crap girl
like you're nuts with money no you're
not I'm not you're not nuts Megan with
money that's that yeah but you are a
daughter who lost her mom and so that
that brain fog the processing that that
has to go through
um what you go through it's a lot and so
was there probably some spending you did
maybe to to feel better and to feel good
and and you know was there a level of
that maybe I'm not sure possibly you
could say yes or no to that but um I
don't want you to to sit there and just
absolutely ring yourself out on this I
mean you've gone through a tragedy and
so
um I think you're starting to kind of
come out of it the way you're talking
and you're kind of seeing okay I need to
kind of get into I need to get my money
in under control I need to start looking
and to see okay how can I be an adult uh
but yet here's my grieving dad over here
but I would say with that relationship
to my again
um you know we love our parents and
honor them
but also he can't be your responsibility
you can't be the thing that saves him
because then that's how you're going to
spend your entire life and he has to be
able to do that work on his own and he
may he may grieve and feel lonely and
all that and you can be a great daughter
and walk beside him and maybe there's
still a season like Jade said that you
don't move out right now right maybe it
all still feels fresh and you're like I
want to get a few things under my belt
and so I'm going to stay here and maybe
have a date that you talk to him about
to say Hey Dad I'm looking at this and
be honest with him and say Dad I'm I'm
nervous to leave I don't want to leave
you I feel bad leaving you and you guys
talk through that
um but also I want you to know Megan you
know you you can't he can't be your you
can't be his responsibility he can't be
your responsibility that's right there
there can't be that that codependence
there um there kind of has to be that
breaking that you do have to stand on
your own at some point but again you
don't have to rush that we're not
telling you to rush it but I do want you
to think about that you're not a bad
daughter or you're not being mean or
cruel if you say man I need to get my
own Apartments yes and start you know
really doing doing my life this way and
all of that that is not negligent or
cruel
um because you're both going to grieve
in different ways yes you know sure and
and that time process is going to be
different for both of you so you might
be at a point where it's like okay like
I feel like I'm coming out of this fog a
little bit I feel like I'm ready to you
know go to this next stage and he might
still be feeling like oh like I could
really use somebody here at the house
but you know that's when it's going to
have be time to have those tough
conversations I do like that you're
looking at your money in that you're
realizing that something's going to have
to change in order for you to stand on
your own when that time comes and I I
love that you're looking at are you
using every dollar
yeah I like so I'm 30. you know what I
mean and like I'm still single and I'm
like I wouldn't want to be a 30 year old
man still living at home sure so that's
like yeah yeah and I think you're you
know yeah like I'm 30 I don't want to be
like 40 having my first child right so
that's right so it's like six and one
half a dozen in the other because it
seems like almost every day for him is a
bad day so yeah has he done do you guys
have a great church a good pastor or
good or a therapist or any anyone
speaking into this process of your mom's
loss he um he goes to church every
Sunday with my aunt and then also I got
him to go to grief share that's great
good good out of local church and I'm
like trying to ease in the counseling
thing like he said probably he might
ought to yeah yeah yeah because because
I mean the big gold too I feel like I
sound like Dr John baloney a little bit
but but to become whole people through
this journey as well I can write there
there can be that level of healing and
so for you that may look like the next
step is to say Hey Dad I'm gonna sit
down and and here's the dates you know
by May of this year
um here's here's what my plan is and I I
still want to
be there for you and still support you
where I can and then Megan you know as
you're calling in for this show
specifically with your money like what
Jade was saying and then you start you
can even start now working the baby
steps you can start now you have the
every dollar app start looking at your
all your credit card debt listed out
list out the car uh keep your retirement
don't cash it out but you have fifteen
thousand dollars of cash which is that's
a wonderful step yep to throw some of
that at the debt start getting some of
these quick wins with your money and
that's also going to breed a level of
confidence for you to maybe even say
okay I can do this
and and start you know living on my own
and and really taking that turn because
you can Mega and you can do this you
definitely can and in every dollar one
of my favorite features Megan is the
financial road map and you can plug in
all your numbers and you can actually
start to see the date that you'll be
debt free the date that you'll have you
know three to six months of savings and
that's something that will build a lot
of confidence and help you to see okay
what would happen if I were to put more
on my debt what would happen if I were
to put Less on my debt so you can really
customize that timeline so that this can
become a real a reality for you moving
forward yeah and hang on the line Megan
because we'll give you and your dad two
separate codes to have Financial Peace
University for a year because I would
love him to maybe go through it as well
on his own because like you said he's
never lived on his own he's always had
someone with him and so giving him a
little bit of boost in this area of his
life we would love to gift both of you
that so Austin will pick up
um
own your pass change your future yes
yeah throw one of those in too throw two
of those in guys for both of them
because we do we want we want to see you
and your dad uh do really well out of
this really excruciating terrible loss
so I'm so sorry Megan I'm glad you
called in
that was a tough call I appreciate you
guys joining us for today that does it
for today's show be sure to join us next
time when it comes to changing your
money you can tell me you won't do it
but please don't tell me you can't this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth we help you do work that you love
and create actual amazing relationships
I'm your host Jade warshaw joined by
Rachel Cruz give us a call today we want
to talk about whatever it is that's on
your mind whatever it is that's been
bugging you to try to make a decision we
want to help you the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and let's go directly to the phone lines
we've got Steven on the line Stevens in
Austin Texas how can we help you today
Stephen
well first of all thank you for taking
one call I I'm listening to you folks
and I believe you guys are awesome and
um
what I want to say is
hey are you in a place where you can
kind of dial it back I just heard a
little something there
yeah
um my job right now but okay
anyway I'm in that corner of the job
here and that's kind of points could die
out of the way okay
how can we help today
well I want to go to move to a different
position
where I've had prior experience
and has the potential to make a lot more
a lot more lucrative career
and
um one place right now where I work is a
big box
Home Improvement store and
um you can be around this place I I you
know they have the benefits here
my health insurance which takes care of
my medications that I take every day or
every month which medications are up
around 10 grand a month
what's your what's what's the health
issue Steve yeah Steven what's what's
going on epilepsy
I'm so sorry
yeah yeah and the biggest part of all
this is me not being able to drive back
and forth to work
um
no I have to have my wife drive me or
right now my father-in-law he's down
here he does it too
so but your health insurance is covering
the cost of your medication for that at
this point
exactly okay my wife's so scared of me
trying to find another job
um because losing my insurance and I
came up with a plan here and it may
sound a little crazy but if I can get
I have you know a bunch of vacation days
I can use in sick time and I could maybe
get you know two or three months worth
of medicine
you know stocked up go and find these
different
uh job offers and interviews that have
been uh have been asked of me to go do
I can I can do that so I've got a list
of prospects you've got a list of jobs
that you're interested in that you're
interested in applying for
and they're interested in me coming to
them okay that's great yeah so yeah so
yeah Stephen you could use some vacation
days
um
for that or if you have a yeah an
interview in the afternoon maybe it's if
it's are you in on an hourly pay right
now oh yes I'm on the hourly pay okay so
yeah so even if you had to take off an
afternoon
um to go and interview with a company
you know to do that for sure but I would
not jump ship until you have another job
solidified because you don't want your
insurance yeah to to yeah I'm with your
wife on that that would be scary if if
you had a gap between quitting this job
and you know waiting I guess for another
job so making sure that you have one
that's secure
um so that you can just move your health
insurance over and and be on a new plan
you know maybe with a new carrier or
whatever that looks like with your new
job and making sure that it has benefits
because yeah of your of your health
situation that is something that you're
going to want
um set up for sure how old are you
Stephen
I'm 40 years old we just had our first
newborn baby congratulations
congratulations how you feeling
oh I'm feeling great
newborns are tough sometimes they are I
like this idea I like the idea of you
looking for work if you're you know
whether it's you're looking to increase
your income or you're looking to
increase your benefits I like that what
I want you to do is really sit down and
dream about where you want to be long
term and you know not just pick
something because it's more money or not
just pick something because of the
benefits but pick something because it's
really something that energizes you uh
like Ken Coleman would say something
that gives you the juice and gets those
juices flowing so that you're doing work
that matters and work that really
matters to you we appreciate that call
Steve and hopefully we were able to help
you out there let's take another call we
got Rob in Denver Colorado what's going
on Rob how can we help today
hey guys how are you doing good how are
you good good good hey quick question
for you my wife and I
um we are in babies text steps four five
and six
and we're kind of
um planning ahead five years out where
do we want to be and we would like to
upgrade in a home uh and my question is
is to start planning uh to make sure
that it's it's a good decision that we
have enough money
is is it best to pay
towards the interest I'm sorry towards
the principle that we have today
um or do we just pay the minimum amount
and then take whatever we have left over
and start saving up for another down
payment what would you guys suggest
building equity in that so there's still
going to be you're going to see that
money again uh it'll just be in equity
and so I would do that and because Rob
there's not like an actual specific like
oh yeah we're moving to that house in
six weeks and you know there's not like
a very very specific plan you just know
you want to upgrade so while that
dreaming is kind of still going uh and
before the logistics are put into place
just keep throwing money at the house
and just be paying that off yep building
that Equity because when you guys do
finally say oh yeah here's the house we
want and you go through the process yeah
you'll have more equity in the house to
roll over to the second house would you
say the same Jade yeah I love that plan
uh and for another reason I think that
whenever you pay it towards your current
mortgage it's a forced it's forced
savings and because it's already gone
into that account you can't touch it so
if you were just putting it into savings
right instead of putting it on your
mortgage let's say you're stacking it up
in a savings account look Hawaii might
be like okay hey next summer yeah yeah I
am I always say because and booboo's
destination wedding it always comes at
the worst possible time right when
you've got right when you've got ten
thousand dollars saved because when
Booboo gets married in the Caribbean and
you gotta go and you gotta go and so
that's why we would suggest go ahead and
throw it to your current mortgage and
when you get ready to move you're gonna
sell the house and you're gonna have
this nice uh little Nest Egg of equity
there so you know Rachel that's the
thing you know we think that we'll save
this money and that we're like such good
Savers and we always do what we say
we're gonna do with our money doesn't
always happen I like to build in the
accountability yes
accountability and net Equity it's a
good question Rob it's a very good
question so that's what we would say to
do anytime that you have money earmarked
for something if you can just build in
that accountability so that you don't
accidentally quotes around accidentally
spend it on something else especially
when it comes to something as major as a
home purchase you definitely want to be
able to do that because he's going to
make money on it and you know he's gonna
have it ready for him started waiting
when it is time this is the Ramsay show
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show
we're here for you whatever you're going
through if it's money if it's
relationships if it's career hey we're
moms if you're a mom and you're just
like Ugh at your wits end give us a call
I'm Jade warshaw this is Rachel Cruz
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and today is a
very special day
yes it is I didn't know about this I
didn't know either today is random acts
of kindness day which I love this
February 17th it says if you're in the
spirit of doing good what better day to
give back than on National random acts
of kindness day February 17th who knew I
know so it started over 40 years ago in
the San Francisco Bay area and a
journalist is credited with coining the
phrase practice random acts of kindness
and senseless acts of beauty love that
so that article was published and it
sparked a kindness movement that spread
to surrounding areas and yeah so it's
just kind of a fun
uh a fun day because we love giving yeah
we talk about generosity a lot on this
show and it's part of the Legacy that
you leave it's part of one of the
reasons why we talk about being wise
with your money and getting out of debt
to have that margin so that you can give
save and spend all the things uh but
giving is a it's a big part and everyone
can participate in random acts of
kindness that's right you don't have to
spend a lot of money kindness is
definitely contagious it doesn't have to
be tons of money I mean you can do
something for five dollars that's right
when whenever somebody gives me one of
those like five dollar Starbucks gift
cards yes it's like woohoo like it's
just such a great way to be kind and you
know we were talking about it last week
I think John and I were on and we were
just saying how with everything going on
inflation and like you know uncertain
economies it's really easy to kind of
like focus our energy on that as opposed
to going okay how do I Rise Above This
and one of the best ways is to take the
focus off of you and all of your like uh
and like constraint and go be generous
yes that's right go do anything and we
should chat let's do a challenge Jade I
like this to everyone listening
go and five bucks it might just be five
dollars random acts of kindness and if
you document it put it on social hashtag
the Ramsay way yes and let's collect
some of these stories and keep the
random acts of kindness from over 40
years ago yes still in place
hashtag the Ramsay way and hey like tag
Us in it like tag at Rachel Cruz tag at
Jade warshaw George Campbell
tag all of us because we want to see
what you're doing we want to share it on
our social we just want to make this
thing contagious because like Rachel
said the whole point of living like no
one else is so that later you can live
and give like no one else and I think
that no matter where you are in the baby
steps there's always a place for
generosity even if it's just a little
bit you can you can do this so oh I love
this random acts of kindness day makes
me feel even better it does it makes me
feel great February 17th don't forget it
and don't forget it it makes me feel so
good I want to take a call from Andrew
and San Jose California what you got
going on Andrew
Hi how are you both doing doing good how
are you
I'm doing I'm doing good
um first thank you for taking my call
giving me a chance to help me with my
question absolutely
simply put uh in the last four to six
months or so I got really caught up just
inflating my lifestyle and now pretty
much got myself in a let's say bad car
situation that maybe I'm just trying to
get out of oh no tell us about it what's
going on
so
um I got a new car that at the time
um I felt like I could handle the
monthly payments but uh it kind of just
feels like you know you don't have much
of a cash flow and uh it's just I really
at this point I'm so I'm sold on selling
the car and the question I have for you
guys is like is it better for me to buy
a car and cash I'll pay down a bit
faster or Finance something like a third
of the cost that'll keep forever what do
you think we're gonna tell you
buy a car in cash yeah
yeah why do you well I'm just playing
devil's advocate here because I want to
see I want to make sure that you know
the reason why because you're feeling
the pinch of this car payment how much
is your car payment Andrew
eleven hundred dollars a month
yep you are feeling that yeah because I
mean that's about how much do you make a
year
I make about last year made a little
over 100 this year I'm gonna try to make
about 120. okay
so you've had the car for three months
and now you're thinking this was a bad
idea so to Jade's question
why do you think that we
are going to suggest to pay for your
next car with cash and not take out
another loan
um
well so I no longer have a monthly
payment and you know help me save up
faster
um and I and yeah that's that's pretty
much my
to give you some some background as far
as why I wasn't even thinking the other
option
um is
really uh my I I've heard you guys give
the advice before tell Billy you know go
buy a three thousand five thousand
dollar car write it and then uh help you
pay down the cash but I
I I'm wondering if if that uh like I'm
I'm worried that I'm gonna get a car
like that and then you know three to six
months it's gonna have a lot of payments
so it's gonna have to like a lot of
fixes or something and I'm end up doing
the same things done I think as long as
you I think it's look I've I've only
I've only driven used cars I've never
had a brand new car in my life and I
think as long as you do the research
check out the Carfax find out as much as
you can about the car and and make a
solid purchase that's thing one and then
thing two we always talk about having an
emergency fund your emergency fund is
there in case something crazy goes wrong
right there's that and then your third
level of protection is you know always
having a sinking fund just sitting there
for regular car maintenance so that
you're taking care of your vehicles and
and you're doing the things like the oil
changes and the tires and changing the
the belts and all I don't know all the
car terminology but you're doing great
Jade you're you're selling me on it you
know the rotator cuff you know whatever
it's called I don't know what that is
but as long as you're the alternator
there you go as long as you are taking
care of your vehicle as long as you have
your emergency fund set aside I think
it's really easy to focus on those
horror stories and and let it talk you
out of doing what's right but I know
plenty of people who have bought new
cars and they've had car troubles so I
think that's just kind of like that that
we hit here's Gonna Be Your Biggest
here's your biggest hurdle are you ready
your ego okay that's it because
you are sitting in a brand new very
expensive car what kind of car is it
it's a Tesla
yeah
this is close to Rachel's heart now
I will have a moment of silence with you
Andrew
I'm so sorry but listen you're gonna
it's gonna hurt your ego is Gonna Hurt
you've been driving around up to work up
with friends going to dinner in your new
Tesla and now you're gonna show up in a
Camry that's right and your ego is going
to take a hit but you know what
guess what your Andrew's gonna have
money again okay Andrew's gonna have
money and that's what you have to focus
on Andrew it's amazing how we just get
so much of we were talking about the
consumerism in the last hour but it's
true I'm like man this this lifestyle
feel and somehow we think if I just had
a nice car uh if I just could go on this
kind of trip if I could have this kind
of house everything will be better I'm
gonna feel better about myself because
our cars have become our identity people
look at your car yeah and they
automatically you know they make a
Solutions make assumptions and so it
takes a level of humility Andrew to say
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna help
Andrew 10 years from now yeah be in a
whole lot better shape to go buy a new
Tesla my goal for you Andrew is to go
back to a new Tesla I would love for you
love for you to be an everyday
millionaire be investing have no debt
cash flow coming in you're making great
money and to be like yeah you know what
I'm gonna go buy a new Tesla and you
don't have to think twice about it come
on drive like no one else so later you
can drive like nowhere call Andrew
that's the goal but this thing is eating
you alive so you're gonna take a hit on
it you're probably going to be
underwater by buying it brand new and
selling it three months later so you're
gonna take a small loan outs for that
difference put that in your debt
snowball go buy a cheap car with three
thousand five thousand dollars it's fine
and if it breaks down in six months
guess what it doesn't lose value go sell
it for three thousand dollars more put a
few more go to go get another car right
like you can keep moving up in car but
it lists out all of your debts Andrew
knock it all out you have a great income
get a solid emergency fund and your
peace of mind Andrew your peace of mind
is going to be so different because
you're actually going to have peace
you're not going to have stress I love
that you got it you got it Andrew but
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
he has to amputate the Tesla it's never
an easy thing to do but he's gonna have
peace because of it look your car is not
your status symbol it does not say
whether or not you are successful or not
what I'm looking at is do you actually
have money Rachel that's right this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
to the Ramsay show I'm Jade warshaw
joined by Rachel Cruz and we're taking
your calls today about life and money go
ahead and give us a call the numbers
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and if you're out there and you're
looking to sell your house right now
trust me it can be intimidating I just
went through this process and since
demand is still higher than Supply home
prices are still Rising regardless of
what all the peoples say home prices are
still rising and the buyers in this
market are serious about finding a deal
that means you may have some tough
decisions to make on a tight timeline
but look you don't have to sell your
home alone and you shouldn't do not try
this on your own people trust me it's
important to work with an expert real
estate agent who knows your local
housing market inside and out and who
will walk you through the selling
process step by step you need a real
estate agent who's earned the right to
be called Ramsay trusted and you can
find one through our endorsed local
providers program Ramsay trusted Pros
who are highly vetted top tier agents my
team and I trust and I do trust let me
tell you something I got my real estate
agent through Ramsay trusted and she was
and still is incredible phenomenal Mandy
lynnfesty you heard it here first she's
incredible love her everything that I'm
talking about right now they have what
it takes to help you sell your home on
your terms and for the best price
wonderful if you're ready to sell your
home get a Ramsay trusted Pro in your
corner it's a free connect today just go
to ramseysolutions.com agent to find one
near you that's ramseysolutions.com
agent you know Jay two nights ago we had
a VIP dinner in Indianapolis before our
Building Wealth event yeah and we had a
group of Ramsay trusted real estate
agents tax professionals
um we had smart faster pros and
investing and some other people that we
have contact with they're in the area of
of Indianapolis so we had a dinner and
you know and we get to you know you and
I and the brands of personalities that
were there you know we get to mingle
kind of before dinner you sit at a table
and just get to know these people and I
sat with a tack a Ramsay trusted tax Pro
and a real estate agent and they are
just those two specifically because I
just had dinner with them I'm like
they're hard for people yes and to help
you guys that's why we recommend people
in your corner especially these very
specific areas of your of your journey
with money yeah uh because investing can
be intimidating selling your home can be
intimidating and buying a home taxes
like all of these areas of your money
having someone that's a professional
that actually cares and loves what they
do yes I mean they love what they do and
getting to help people so make sure to
check this out because we vet these
people and we just wanna we want you
guys to have a level of Financial Peace
and Freedom with your money and having
good people on your team that's right is
so so huge it takes I mean it takes the
stress out of it it does yes when we
were looking for a house here in
Tennessee
my girl my girl my my real estate agent
she came through she came all the way
through so definitely get with a Ramsay
uh trusted Pro in your area let's take a
call let's take Philip what's going on
Philip from Indianapolis Indiana
hey I was actually there last night at
the building welcome hey
awesome I love the energy in there so
I'm
gonna feel like I need some
encouragement maybe I was kick in the
pants or both oh we can do that yeah I'm
34 I've got uh 200 000 left in debt um
about 150 000 of that student loans and
then uh the rest is credit cards that
I'm paying off a 401k loan
um and my current employer offers
two dollars for every dollar that I put
into my retirement and so if I put in
500 which is what I've been doing they
add a thousand every single month and so
I put in six thousand a year they add
twelve thousand
um and I just have been struggling so
hard giving that up
um because it's like a 200 return on
investment immediately but I but I have
this debt looming over my head and I
don't I can't afford a down payment on a
house like I'm still renting and so I'm
like I just need to know that I'm gonna
be okay
um if I pause that for a few years which
is probably how long it's going to take
me to get out of this two hundred
thousand dollars in the hole what's your
income right now Philip
I'm a pharmacist and a professor so it's
about a hundred and ten thousand okay um
and my I recently got married another a
third kid on the way oh congratulations
does your wife work
she's working part-time because she's in
nursing school right now okay so she's
only making about 20 000 right now okay
um was that included in the 110
or is that in addition to about in
addition to so about at 1 30 for the
household currently all right you know
of course I'm gonna always refer back to
the baby steps because we know that this
is a proven method I mean millions of
people have used this not only to get
out of debt but you know to find
Financial Freedom and go on to become
baby steps millionaires so we know that
this method works so let me precursor it
with that but yeah that match is going
to be there
that match is going to be there and
right now you need all of the money that
you can to throw at your debt snowball
so that you can get it done as quickly
as possible and here's the thing when
you're done getting out of debt you're
going to have so much more money to put
towards retirement you're going to be
able to make up the you're going to make
up the difference and what I would
suggest doing this is like my new
favorite thing if you're not using every
dollar Philip I would get on
everydollar.com every dollar premium
and use the financial roadmap planner
because that's we're going to plug in
all these numbers and you're going to be
able to see like the actual math of if
I'm putting this much per month towards
my debt how quickly can I have it paid
off that's thing one but then it's also
going to project out for you Phillip
what the final scenario is going to be
you're going to be able to find out when
you're three to six months is saved
you're going to become a baby steps
millionaire and it's so motivating and I
trust me once you plug the numbers in
there you're not going to be worried
about you know the little bit of money
that you're going to lose on this match
because you're going to realize oh my
gosh I'm going to be debt free in like I
don't know 24 to 36 months yes right I
know I was going to say so pausing for
three years Philip I'll talk to you off
the ledge you're gonna be fine it's fine
but guess what you're going to press
play
and start investing again and then like
what Jade said when you have that income
you know and you guys buy a house you're
gonna be saving up for a down payment
you guys are going to be doing some
really great financial moves that you're
actually going to have the money for uh
and and the less stress because here's
the other thing Philip that you're not
probably taking into account is what
this 200
000 debt is doing to you guys the stress
the lack of sleep you know we talk about
even your even within your body your
body knows that you are not safe when
you don't have autonomy and when you owe
student loans and MasterCard and all
this other people
have a say over your future there's a
level that you are still owned by them
and there is a true emotional spiritual
lifting that happens when you don't owe
someone money and that Philip
I don't care what employer does a match
of any kind right like that level of
just freedom and peace of mind that you
guys don't owe anyone anything suddenly
you may realize they don't want to
switch jobs you know what if that other
employer has a three percent match
wasn't as great as my other one but I
have the freedom to create a life that I
love love it because I am not tied to
these payments so there is a there is a
mathematical reassurance that we'll give
you on that side that pausing Investing
For for three years or whatever it is
you're gonna be okay you're still young
you're fine we would give the same
advice actually if you were 50 I mean
you know it's the same advice I think I
needed to hear the
um you know all of this is really
helpful and I think the the clarity is
something that I'm just not I haven't
seen yet and so yesterday I started
plugging in all these compound
calculators and I'm like oh wow this is
going to be many millions because I
currently have 180 000 in retirement
already and so I'm like if I did nothing
I would have over a million dollars
that's right yeah like why can I not
make the jump here to actually like do
something about this that but I think
the road map is actually going to be the
most helpful thing for me because I'm
I'm someone just got to see the numbers
and know that this is heading the right
direction so I really appreciate
um you know the insight and
encouragement because I've been looking
for it for a little while and I haven't
been able to get myself over the hump so
yes appreciate you guys so much
absolutely we are so happy to help and
you know that's a really good thing that
he brings up Rachel because it happens
all the time that people you know
they're like man I don't want to stop my
investing I don't want to pause but they
don't think they're going to be okay can
I tell it took us seven and a half years
yep of not investing we didn't get to
start investing until our mid-30s you
are going to be okay because you're
going to invest one day like you're
gonna invest it's gonna happen I ain't
got nothing else to do with my money
Rachel would invest it it's all going
into there and I'm like I look at it and
I don't go oh man what if I go yeah baby
that's right this is happening
everything they told me was gonna happen
is happening so it is not too late for
you I promise you that this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show we are on with
Rachel Cruz myself Jade warshaw guys if
you have questions about anything I
don't care what it is it could be
retirement it could be inflation it
could be meal planning whatever it is
that's on your heart and mind give us a
call today the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we want
to discuss it because chances are
whatever it is that's bugging you it's
probably not just bugging you it's
probably bugging a bunch of other people
too whatever question you have it's
probably not just you there's probably a
lot of other people that have questions
too so give us a call right now we're
going to go to the phone lines we've got
Debbie in Huntington West Virginia
what's going on in West Virginia Debbie
hello thank you for taking my call
you're welcome
um about about a year ago maybe a year
and a half ago I bought a car for my son
I co-signed for a car it was a 2017
Veloster Turbo okay and he drove it for
about uh eight months making the
payments he has a good job and he goes
to work every day so I was proud of him
for that he makes good money okay and um
uh apparently he didn't have the credit
so they flipped it around and put it in
my name and put him underneath me I
didn't know that though so meanwhile on
the way to vacation
his transmission goes out
and he's not with me so they tow it off
and they told him it's going to be nine
thousand dollars to fix it and it has
under a hundred thousand miles on it
okay so it ends up that they said we
didn't have any warranty but it ends up
I had it towed back to home and they
said yes you do have warranty on it and
the transmission can be replaced but so
it was in limbo for like four or five
months without being fixed because it
took them forever to get it done okay
then during that time my son lost his
license how did that happen
uh long distance driving to a girlfriend
and he got tickets for speeding on the
interstate
license okay how old is your son Debbie
well
and he's 21. okay now okay so you spend
the 9k to fix the transmission
right it didn't cost me anything it
ended up being free but the warranty
okay paid eight I paid 18 for the corn
we still owe 15 and he really can't
drive the car because he doesn't have
license is he still working I don't
yes he is okay so where's the how can I
help you today
well
um
when you lose your license your
insurance goes up he's no longer allowed
on our insurance because of that okay so
he's got like 24 points
um and then
because of that he's not going to be
able to afford to make the house the car
payment and the insurance what's it
what's his name Debbie what's his name
it is Jim Jim okay I got I got a plan
for Jim and you Debbie you ready
yes I'd sell the car today
for 18. I mean you have three thousand
dollars left
I would give it to Jim if you guys are
in a good position no no it'll be turned
around we're gonna owe more than we can
get out of it you said you said it was
worth 18 and you owe 15. I paid 18. are
you paid 18. what is worth what's it
worth you think
one of the dealers said they'd give us
like 10. okay I think if we sold it out
right okay I might be able to get more
all right so Jim isn't going to like my
my plan as I continue down this road but
I like it Rachel Debbie get rid of it
Debbie and you're gonna take a small
loan of five thousand dollars you know
what we call that Debbie around here
stupid tax
and we've all done it
we've all been in positions where we
think why did I do that why did I
co-sign and now my name is she was being
a good mom she was just she just thought
she was doing the the motherly thing and
so Jim Jim is 21 is he and he's living
at home and that's you I'm not gonna rag
on that but but Jim is 21 and he's gonna
have to learn I have a long distance
girlfriend
I have to now figure out my insurances
up because I drove fast and got multiple
speeding tickets I have lost my license
my insurance is up Debbie this is not
your problem nope Jim has a lot of
problems and Mommy does it but Debbie
doesn't Debbie has a 5 000 problem that
you're gonna have to just you're gonna
pay but I would I would just I I just
he's he's got to learn and it's this
isn't like a tough love like but for you
Debbie I'm looking out for you because
I'm like man you could you know you
again good Hearts like you said Jade the
intention was good but Debbie I want you
guys I want you to be in a position that
you are being wise with your money and
this and this isn't this isn't wise in
fact what's the scripture about
co-signing Jade to paraphrase to
paraphrase the scriptures it says that a
person who co-signs is stupid we're not
calling you stupid Debbie the Bible did
no I'm just kidding but it is saying the
act of doing that because you never know
what's going to happen and this is a
this is a very very good teaching point
for everybody listening right now I'm
sorry to put you on this pedestal Debbie
but it's a great teaching segment
because if there's any situation where
somebody would think I can co-sign for
this person they're not going to do me
wrong it is mother to son right yeah
it's the purest it's the purest
relationship right there purist of
intent but Jim Jim took you for a ride
well and they flipped it on her yeah
that when they pulled the credit they
put her name on there so I'm like I
don't want you liable Debbie with this
car like I don't trust that I don't I
don't like it that's right um but that's
what they do and you know what Debbie
and and we have to we're gonna have to
go to a break soon so I can't get all
this information from you but depending
on
your situation Debbie if you are in a
financial position I'm thinking you're
not because you went and got a car alarm
and all of that but for some reason if
you did have
you know some money to spare after this
debt is cleaned up and you want to help
Jim out and say hey Jim I will match you
for your car you know you save 3 000 and
I and I will help you with three
thousand to get you a six thousand you
know like yeah if there's ways to help
without enabling that's true and so if
there is a type of plan like that you
want to do you can but I want you Debbie
in a solid Financial Foundation meaning
all of your debts paid off including
this new five thousand dollar loan that
you're gonna have after the car is sold
um you have an emergency fund in place
like you are set up Debbie Jim is 21 he
has his whole life to figure this he
sure does and and you know what I mean
and you're and you're the mom so you're
in the middle and of the of the age
range so it's like I want you in a good
position for retirement yes and thank
you Lord so again it's uh it was out of
a good place it was out of a Mom's heart
and it just it was the word it's this is
what happens though the worst happens
people think it's gonna be fine yeah and
then it happens so Debbie I'm so sorry
because signing is the worst yeah don't
do it we weren't calling Debbie stupid
but the Bible does say that it is stupid
to sign Assurance or to co-sign for
someone else can I tell you guys a
secret live on here when I was dating
Sam yes I quote and and big quotes
needed a new car yes you did before
Taurus uh that had lots of special
features the heat didn't work like and
Sam was like you need a new car he took
me and I have of course had terrible
credit he co-signed for my car yeah the
dumbest thing ever we were not even
engaged
so let me tell you I know something to
because here's the thing if you're
co-signing it means that that person
cannot get they can't get the loan
themselves which means the bank knows
they ain't got no money the bank knows
they can't be trusted yeah that's the
whole point of co-signing so think about
that for a minute you're putting your
neck on the line for something that and
Banks they would love to give you money
that's right they're right there for you
man they'll give money to they'll get
money to anybody and if they won't give
money to this person that is saying
something like that register red flag to
not sign for them so if we're calling
Debbie stupid I'm calling myself stupid
and I'm calling no we're not calling
Debbie stupid at all I'm just saying the
scriptures got us on lock on the the
scripture put us in a headlock on this
one don't co-sign the loan now and I
love what Rachel said because when my
kids get older and they get to driving
age the plan is to buy cars in cash yes
you know yeah they're gonna recommend
anyway I know they're gonna get dinged
up they're gonna get scratched up yes I
for sure would never a brand new car no
for well for a 16 year old no no no no
but don't you remember not until not yes
in high school people would come rolling
through with brand new cars yes yes they
would oh yes they would don't do it no
not worth it yeah the car thing it is uh
oh it's the piece of debt that I'm like
man the car loan borrowing money on
something going down in value all of it
but yes do not do it thanks for calling
Debbie it was a great call it's
something that we can all all learn from
we've all done stupid things the point
is that we learn from it and because we
took that call somebody is going to
avoid the Perils of co-signing all right
folks that does it for today's show be
sure to join us next time and remember
this when it comes to changing your life
and your money you can tell me that you
won't do it but please please do not
tell me you can't with Christ all things
are possible this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm your
host Jade warshaw today joined by my
friend Rachel Cruz so good to be with
you Jay it's so great I hope I'm hosting
with you I do too I do too when I saw
our names for Friday I thought it's
gonna be a good day oh yeah it's gonna
be a good day it's gonna be good we want
to take your calls whatever it is that's
on your heart what's on your mind today
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're gonna go straight to the phone
lines we've got Kayla in Dallas Texas
what's going on Kayla
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
absolutely I'm calling because I just
started FPU and I'm being super
compliant because my way has clearly not
worked so you still want to do it the
Ramsay way but I have questions
um just about credit like I've cut up my
credit cards
um as per you know the sets
um I'm going for it with it but my
concern is I'm in a studio right now
what if I need to like I don't know rent
another apartment don't I need credit
for that like maybe I've been
brainwashed a little bit too much but I
just wanted to ask the professionals
sure that's a really good I mean that's
something that I think a lot of people
worry about is how am I supposed to live
life without a credit score it's
definitely possible you know they do use
other things to look at your credit
history they'll look at things like cell
phone they'll look at so many other ways
of you paying back debt but do be
prepared because when it comes to uh
renting an apartment if you don't have
credit you are a lot of times gonna have
to pay more money up front when it comes
like first to last month's rent and
things like that a lot of times at least
in my experience they have asked for
more money up front
um we see this too with renting cars and
things like that sometimes we get the
short end of the stick because of the
way that we're choosing to live our life
without debt but it's still absolutely
possible uh do you have anything to add
to that Rachel yeah I mean I would say
Kayla usually most apartment complexes
that we you know as we've done this and
heard from people
if you have your first month's rent last
month's rent security deposit and like
Jade said other bills to prove that you
pay on time it's not going to be debt
but cell phone insurance your current
rent that you're renting now like
keeping kind of a ledger of that stuff
just to prove and show I mean
electricity right like any bill that you
have to say hey here's my here's my
history for the last six months of
payment here's first month's rent last
month's rent security deposit all in
full uh most places will still run
through that apartment but if they say
no guess what you get to go right about
half a mile down okay to another complex
and say hey here's my situation you know
you may have to go shop around but
people are stay you can still rent in
apartments there's still people that do
that that will rent you the apartment uh
renting cars I mean anything and
everything it is still possible to do
without a credit score without a credit
card all the above but it but like Jade
said though Kayla it's not just a plug
and play because companies now use this
score for a lot of different things so
there is going to be some Runner round a
little bit but let me tell you the
runaround is so much worth it than
having to sit there and pay a bunch of
credit card bills and car loans so I
would rather take the extra energy and
go and do that and you'll do the same
thing Caleb when you want to purchase a
home you'll do manual underwriting to
get your mortgage versus a credit score
again it's going to take a level of
extra paperwork extra effort but the
extra effort is so much worth it when
you are free and you don't owe anyone
anything I know that's right I'm proud
of you Kayla for doing this man you cut
up the credit cards like you're in it
you're doing it you're doing a great job
that's the thing I said I wasn't going
to do either but my way doesn't work
that's right just try it because here's
the deal we always say too if you do
this for six months you get out of debt
and you hate being debt free it'll be
there waiting for you you can go you can
go right back in it's way easier to go
into debt than it is to get out so yeah
there's always your chance if that's
what you want but I'm telling you Kayla
once you taste that freedom you're
you're not going to want to go back man
she's doing a great job but she brings
up a really interesting point because
you know with with when it comes to
Apartments you know it that is the thing
people think man like how am I going to
get out of this but one thing I would
say for anybody listening if you're
renting even if you're renting like even
if you're living with your parents right
but you're paying rent to them keep
record of that yeah like actually write
them a check or do like a a transfer
something that you can keep record of
because when you are ready to move out
whether it be into your own home or into
an apartment they want to see a history
that you've been paying rent and I think
a lot of times I'm Kayla wasn't living
with her parents but a lot of times when
people are living with their parents it
kind of lackadaisical it's like oh you
know my mom you know I give her some
money here or there but it's really
important to keep record of that because
some at some point you are going to want
to move out it's a great point and you
need to have record of that so yeah we
have actually a fine print episode
episode seven of the podcast the fine
print it's the dirty truth behind your
credit score and George Campbell walks
you through every scenario yes about
when you need a credit score or and how
you can get around it without a credit
score so make sure to check out that
episode again of the fine print episode
seven I feel that that'll be helpful
that'll be very helpful I remember that
episode so folks if you listen to the
Ramsay show we're on five days a week
all the time on podcasts you can come on
any day and there's probably going to be
episodes on there new episodes can you
share it if this show has helped you in
any way consider sharing the show with
somebody go on to YouTube like the show
leave a positive review but let me tell
you something don't don't be leaving any
negative comment comments no I have
nothing nice to say don't say anything
that's that's what mama said if you
don't have anything nice to say don't
say anything at all because I've seen
some of you in the comments don't think
I don't see it I you know it's so funny
to me and again if that's what you guys
want to do it whatever but it's a free
country I
I just don't I don't think unless I
bought a product and it was just crap
and I'm like I need other people to know
sure not to buy this because it's a
scale or whatever the thing is like it
doesn't look like the picture or
whatever but like on people's podcasts
or even their Instagram picture like
yeah it's just so funny I just can't I
would never I just don't I just can't I
I don't even I don't even have the
energy like I see something I don't like
and I just kind of keep going I'm like I
got kids screaming I have worked like I
have things to do I I don't have the
energy to sit there Jade I impress the
comment button and and and type and
write a whole thing and write it I don't
know I just don't it's just funny to me
I don't know why I don't know why look
but I somebody told me that my my
sweater looked like Fruity Pebbles hey I
got one someone said it's a guiltiest
charge question for a smart money Happy
Hour podcast and I got a direct message
and she said I don't have a guilty as
charge question but you are guilty of
wearing the ugliest sweater I've ever
seen and I was like oh well sorry Ashley
Ashley from Idaho sorry I like my
sweater oh yeah that's what she said to
me I was like geez that would collect
all of these and do a segment on them we
should do a segment of all the mean
comments all the mean comments we get
James my favorite and and honestly I
should probably go on there and say
thank you my favorite comment was from
last week somebody said Jade warshaw has
the biggest lips of all the
personalities and you said that's right
I was like that's right and this ain't
injection
to have Jade worship okay but this is
all we're saying come on there leave a
comment tell people how much you love
this show right how much it's helped you
share it with the neighbor because the
honestly what we're sharing on here is
life-changing people are transforming
their entire lives because of these
principles I'm one of these people
Rachel I know you're one of these people
this this show the content that we're
talking about guys it is powerful
powerful stuff like share subscribe we
would really appreciate it it doesn't
cost you a thing this this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz and
as always we're taking calls about your
life whatever's going on in your life
your money it could be something like
taxes because it's tax season and I know
that a lot of you are like oh my gosh
this time of year it's so stressful it
does not need to feel like that a lot of
you have questions about taxes we
totally get that taxes are confusing can
we just admit that right now Rachel that
taxes so so to help you get I'm not
great at it oh I give it to Winston and
then we go get help but I'm like I I
don't want to deal with it yeah it
stresses me out and that is the correct
stance to take Rachel cruzack that is
correct so to help you get a better a
better handle on them let us let us
unpack a couple of questions from our
listeners because this is stuff that we
all deal about deal with so one listener
says I'm so confused about the child tax
credit this year why haven't I gotten
mine from last year all right A lot of
people are asking that question and
here's the deal
here's what's up with the child tax
credit during covid the government made
changes to it and that kind of affected
the way we viewed it right we thought oh
this is normal but that wasn't normal
that was just because of covid so during
covid this tax credit already existed
but they increased the amount
yeah so you're seeing like you know
depending on how many kids you had that
much money was going you know into your
account so parents got half of that
money up front in monthly installments
do you guys remember that we were all
getting you know however many kids you
got some people getting 600 some people
were getting you know 900 that sort of
deal and people got used to that money
Rachel yes and then the policies changed
and things went back to normal and that
money went away so the other half was
given when you filed your taxes which is
the normal way
um in this change expired because state
of emergency was over so that change
expired December 2021 so that means
we're now back to business as usual it
didn't go way it just means that you can
claim the child tax credit which is two
thousand dollars per qualifying child
under age 17 when you file your taxes
you're not getting it ahead of time and
installments they're just adding it to
your taxes like they used to so for more
tips uh and software that can help you
file with confidence go ahead and head
to ramsaysolutions.com Smart tax Ramsay
smart tax will guide you through the
online process with low upfront pricing
and Rachel no hidden fees I love that
again ramseysolutions.com smart tax if
you have any questions about it we're
here for you and we're here taking your
questions today about your life your
money give us a call the call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five we are here to answer your
questions so let's take a call now we're
going to go to Benjamin in Detroit
what's going on Benjamin
what's going on hey Jade yeah Rachel hey
it's a pleasure to get to talk to you
all thanks for taking my call absolutely
thanks for calling in how can we help oh
yeah and uh well I'm calling because um
well you know my wife and I we're on
baby step 3B
um we've uh you know within two years we
got out about you know just over 65 000
in debt and we're super excited about
not only anyone it's been good congrats
but the question has been uh we we've
we've uh discussed it a couple of times
before and trying to figure out like
guidelines for merging our our health
insurance like we've merged our finances
but health insurance is uh you know it's
another item and you know we're both
paying for it but yeah I'm just curious
like what are their thoughts and what
are the um the directions or guidelines
for merging health insurance and is it
is it absolutely necessary like the
finances yeah no it is not you want to
find the cheapest option and so in fact
how we at in our house Benjamin my
husband has his own he's on his own
policy and it's cheaper for me to have
just the kids
just the way that the policies work uh
versus us doing a big family plan it's
actually cheaper for Winston to be on
his own uh so no that the idea of
merging money when it comes to getting
married is an idea of unity and Oneness
but with health insurance specifically I
would say just to have the best deal so
look at different plans
um if your wife works if you work if
you're getting it through an employer
both pull up and say hey okay is it
cheaper to have an individual plan here
and then a family plan there or is it
cheaper to do the whole family plan
together uh so yeah I would look to see
what is what's the what's the cheapest
for you guys with the coverage that you
guys want do you get health do both of
you get health as a benefit through your
work or are you self-employed
um we we both get a benefit through work
and uh you know the paperwork is so wild
and hard to read like this is a person
that can really talk through that well
usually your HR yeah your the HR of the
company you should be able to sit down
and and look at the different plans and
get a really
um I mean what I would do because
they're in that stuff day in and day out
I know rhr Department man they they are
looking at stuff constantly and so uh I
would even say Benjamin to just tell
your HR Director like Hey listen I this
is a lot and I need this like dumbed
down like that's what I would say give
me the fifth grade level of all the
different options because you're going
to have option A B C or you know
whatever it is uh get that have your
wife do the same and y'all just sit down
one night and say okay let's just price
this out you know if what would it look
like
um for the kids to be on mine over here
what's the family plan there what's the
family plan at her work what's the
individual plan at her work and you know
you can kind of just piece it together
but you're going to want all that
information and ask them to do it not
just to print off an 80-page pamphlet or
something you know for you allow them to
go through it and help you understand it
that's right yeah but it's a that's a
great great question that is a great
question does that give you the answer
that you need
oh that definitely gives me the answer I
you know I'll definitely keep going back
and listening over again and um yeah we
have to get together and talk about it
hello good good one well congratulations
on paying off 65
000 of debt that's super duper excited
that's right and today's question Jade
comes from Rick in Iowa I am new to the
program so I have a quick dumb question
there are no there are no doubts that's
right
uh mentally mentally I want to keep
maxing out my 401k and my 457 I think
it's against your steps but I don't want
to miss out on a year of doing this if I
stop for a year and pay off my debt I
will lose a lot of investing and maybe a
little tax benefit everyone's situation
is different but I'm not sure what to do
thanks for your advice so
we definitely still Rick would recommend
pausing while you have debts and if you
miss out for a year you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be fine because you're
gonna have money you're gonna have money
yep you're able to invest more and this
is how it works yeah when people are
focused especially when it comes to baby
step two and paying off debt the more
focused and plans you are and every part
every ounce of your income that you have
to go to this debt and you are this it's
an intense Focus yeah it does something
and when you say hey I'm going to pause
this thing over here that I really want
let that be a level of motivation to be
like I want to keep investing so like
I'm going to pay this off as quickly as
possible exactly so I can get to that
exactly most people they can't wait to
start investing let that fuel your fire
to go even quickly even more quickly
yeah through getting getting your debt
paid off getting three to six months
saved up because here's the thing the
baby steps work when you work them and
they work when you work them in order
and what happens all the time I see it
all the time people get excited because
they're they're looking at Tick Tock
they're looking at Instagram and they're
seeing all these videos about compound
interest and investing and they get
hyped up which you should right like
investing is exciting however if you
start investing too soon you don't have
an emergency fund and you've got a bunch
of debt Murphy comes that's right
something's gonna happen and then people
take out money out there for 1K or they
are they just alone against it and then
it just ends up being a terrible mess
401K loans I mean we're seeing more and
more of them now and it's like if you
would just work the baby steps in order
and the thing is here's the thing most
people are not investing 15 right now
like right they're investing three up to
the map to the match and it's like if
you work the baby steps when you get to
baby step four you're investing 15
that's a that's a pretty that's more
than we give to the Lord's House okay
10 is the Tie then here we are given 15
that's excellent yeah so much money you
are going to more than make up for it
yeah you're gonna be just fine it's
better to walk the steps in order than
to knock you know and then it's like
next thing you know you're taking out a
401k loan for Beyonce tickets oh have
you seen that girl have I seen it I I
got some articles sent to me and I was
like what what is happening 401K loans
Queen B for Queen B it's still not
worthy it's not worth it a ten percent
penalty and having to pay income taxes
no on that 401k loan someone took um
took a uh took Equity out of their house
without a loan off their house for
Taylor Swift tickets I heard that one
too yep oh don't do it don't do it see
on the soul there's no such thing as
this just go to YouTube and watch music
videos no such thing as a no questions
but dumb things it's a little single
single ladies oh that's the single
ladies
don't do it do not do it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsay show and
live in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions on
the debt free stage we've got Michael
what's going on Michael how you doing
I'm doing great how are you I'm good
where are you from uh I was born in
Chatsworth Georgia and I work in Duluth
Georgia right now awesome awesome so
you're obviously here to do your debt
free scream how much debt have you paid
off uh almost thirty thousand dollars 29
and a half whoa
how long did it take you two years and
three months nice right on point and
what was your range of like what were
you making during that time when you did
it the range is pretty big so when I
started
um I was a long-term sub and I made
about a hundred dollars a day so and
then I went part-time so I started at
about seventeen thousand dollars and did
some side gigs and got it up to about
twenty one thousand uh and I think I
made close to fifty four thousand this
past year nice nice just climbing and
climbing and climbing very very cool so
what happened to kind of get you what
got your juices flowing that said I
gotta get this debt paid off
well once I started working
um
I was getting money to keep teaching
teachers were getting a lot of money
money to not quit basically Brian Kemp
was giving us some money uh and there
was coveted relief funds and I thought
it would be a great gift to my parents
uh who were here with me today to pay
off my car my mom was making the car
payment every month and I just thought
it would be a kind gesture if anything
and then someone said something about
this debt snowball thing in this Dave
Ramsey Show and I listened to it in the
first hour I I realized I had twenty two
thousand dollars more to go plus the
credit card debt
um and I was like it would be great to
start off the rest of my career in my
life
debt free everything in the positive to
have a positive net worth so that was
the goal wow so you had you said car car
note debt credit card debt was there
anything else rolled into that 30k yes
22 and a half thousand dollars of
student loans yes oh Sally May of course
I know it's assumed now you know
oh amazing job okay so what were the
things that you did to help you get out
of debt because there's other Michaels
listening right now they're thinking
absolutely man his story this is this is
me
where do I even begin what do I do what
were the things that really got you
progress quickly the budget using the
every that every dollar app every day
um and I found just by keeping track of
it you make better decisions
um and I was a thousand to two thousand
dollars every month to the student loans
for two years and it was a little over
fifty percent of my income wow having
two roommates certainly helps having my
my parents help
um it was a lot but you know to buy a
five dollar coffee from Starbucks is one
thing but to then have to go home open
up the app and type into the computer I
spent five dollars on a coffee you're
less likely to do that every day so for
sure keeping the budget was the biggest
thing I mean and you really for two
years paying off thirty thousand and
with that income I mean you really
shrank your lifestyle and you upped your
income obviously through that process
but I'm like that that math that you
really sacrificed in those two years
yeah it feel like it was it was it hard
yeah the biggest thing I had to give up
was eating out the coffee
um and Legos I'm a big Legos guy I
haven't bought Legos in two years and
it's expensive yes especially as soon as
I started Lego was coming out with six
seven eight hundred dollar Lego sets
it's just wow that's so bad
um but I I had to stop so so was it
worth it was it the thing that you loved
the most was it worth it to sacrifice
temporarily absolutely absolutely and
now if I had room for it I don't have
room for it all those Lego sets but I
could certainly do that but now I'm
working on the emergency fund so yes
I'll keep putting it off for a few more
years that's so great so your parents
are sitting over here uh in the lobby
I'm assuming they're your parents yes
ma'am uh
I'm sure they're very proud very very
proud of you so were they some of your
big cheerleaders in this time or who
else was kind of cheering you on through
this journey they were certainly my
biggest cheerleaders and my biggest
financial help
um you know college costs a lot more
than twenty two thousand dollars and
they helped me cover a lot of it so we
only took out that much
um and like I said my mom was trying to
pay on my car and at the beginning of
this my other cheerleaders were my My
Fabulous co-workers in the fine arts
department they were always asking me
how much is left how much did I pay this
month oh that's great what did I do with
that Christmas bonus oh wow built-in
accountability yes
um so certainly them those those are my
big cheerleaders my co-workers and my
family I love it love it love it so we
know the Legos like that was a big
sacrifice what was but emotionally like
what was the hardest part of this
journey because you ran it two years I
mean that's nothing to sneeze that two
years what was the hardest part like
what was the part that every day it was
like okay like I just gotta keep doing
XYZ there were there was a point
looking forward to like the five and ten
thousands really got me through it
because I paid off the car I paid off
the credit card and then I got to 20 000
and then it seemed like forever like no
progress was being made I would pay
thousands of dollars still owed 17 and
then one day I was under 10 it was like
the home stretch wow um so that was what
really got me through but it just felt
like forever those two years especially
right in the middle yeah so how did it
how does it feel now
age
it's all paid off the twenty thousand
dollar Mountain has been climbed and
conquered by you
and now you sit on this side with no
payments how does it feel it's like
Freedom it's I can go anywhere in the
world I could save up I could buy a new
car and or not a new car a used car just
by saving up you know a thousand dollars
a month for the next two years I could
get a really nice car if I wanted so you
know being 24 almost 25 now in in
looking at everything with with
opportunity
that's the best feeling I love that yeah
the world is your oyster I know and
what's so exciting for you is that we
see people on the stage a lot and then
we we walk with them through their whole
journey
and it's so many of them one of the
biggest things I say is I wish I had
done this earlier yes and so what is so
great about your story honestly is your
age your stage of life and you're like
I'm gonna clean this up now when I'm
young yep and that way I mean the wealth
you're gonna build the investing you're
gonna be able to do the generosity
that's going to flow from you and your
life that is a beautiful beautiful
Legacy and so it's just it's incredible
incredible to see it because I know it's
hard and I know people probably made fun
of you and you're thinking oh God this
is I want to enjoy life and I'm here
sacrificing but those two years give you
the next 20 40 Years of your life how
old are you by the freedom I'm 24. oh
24. I cannot wait you're gonna be back
on that stage baby steps millionaire man
we are so so so proud of you well we've
got the live and give box for you that's
your chance to gift you know everything
you've learned you know everything
that's brought you to this point you can
gift it to somebody else it includes
Total Money Makeover uh baby steps
Millionaires and a year of FPU you so
you can gift that to somebody else but
without further Ado are you ready for
this we've got Michael he is here and he
is doing his debt free scream he's paid
off 30k and almost two years making 17K
to 54k are you ready to count it down
yes all right let's hear your debts free
scream three two one I'm debt free
oh my goodness gracious so great that's
what it's about Rachel that is what it's
about this guy was willing to sacrifice
to win he took the he heard the message
and he applied it and you know what and
it's and it's everyday people that are
doing this it's everyday people and they
just decide yes to make a change yes and
the other thing that we see consistently
is that they believe they can yes to
those of you out there that you're
overwhelmed you feel like the news is
yelling at you about inflation and job
reports there's fear you don't know
what's going on you feel out of control
I'm telling you there is a system a plan
that anyone can do yes regardless of
your income regardless of your debt
level that's right the timeline may be
different and will be different for
every single one of you out there but
Michael is living proof that's right
that you can one day decide I'm done
that's right Financial Peace University
that is the plan if you can get enrolled
in Financial Peace University as a
matter of fact I'm doing a class you're
coordinating right donating it starts
March 1st even if you don't look I love
if you signed up for my class but even
if you don't please get hooked up with
financial peace I was talking to a girl
online just before the segment and she
was like oh I don't I just don't know if
I want to commit commit because if you
commit you could end up like Michael on
stage in just a short period of time
declaring that you're debt free a man is
worth the time it's worth the effort
getting out of debt guys you can change
your life we believe you can do it now
it's time for you to believe you can do
it and get signed up to make that change
today this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined this hour
by Rachel Cruz and we're taking calls
about your life and your money the
number is easy it's Triple A
825-5225 and we've got our scripture and
quote of the day oh I love this one
before we have brought nothing into the
world so we cannot take anything out of
it either oh that's poignant I love that
one and Priscilla schreier
yes contentment is the equilibrium
between the enjoyment of life now and
the anticipation of what is to come
that's good oh that is good that is good
I love Priscilla she's got some good
stuff she is good and her brother
Anthony Evans yeah such a great singer
all right guys this week in the Ramsay
newsletter we are going to be exploring
10 things that people do to be
successful in retirement I'm interested
in that daydreaming about retirement is
one thing but actually getting to live
those dreams takes very careful planning
we'll lay out the steps for a great
retirement so you can make your golden
years your best years simply sign up for
free at ramseysolutions.com newsletter
to subscribe to our Sunday newsletter to
get the full list I am really loving
this company newsletter because it's
different like yes there's always good
content such good content you never know
what's going to be in there but I can
guarantee you this it will be helpful so
with that let's go to the phone lines
we've got a caller calling in this is
Christine from Seattle Washington how
can we help you today Christine
hi ladies I'm so excited to talk to you
hello we're excited to talk to you too
so um I have a question
um I'm in bs2 right now and my husband
wants to have bariatric surgery which is
great I've had it as well it's been
life-changing but with be in my
insurance will cover most of it I'm not
worried about that part my husband does
construction so part of the post-op
recovery is not lifting a lot and so
it'll be about six weeks for recovery
for him so during that six weeks when we
won't be getting a paycheck from him
so what's the best way to save for
for them because it's usually about a
six-month process to go meet the
criteria for insurance to cover it so we
have some time yeah to save but how do I
uh save for that how do we say for that
while paying off debt I think that in
this case well first off is his doctor
suggesting that he had this surgery or
is it just kind of elective the doc the
doc is suggesting it okay in that case I
would pause baby step two I would pause
baby step two and I would stack up all
the cash yeah that you need to get this
done because you're you're gonna have
the deductible most likely you're gonna
have the loss of income because of the
recovery time and in this case it's kind
of like one of those mini it's just a
few things that we would pause the baby
steps for but this qualifies as one of
them like yes major health situation so
I would pause them do you know how much
it's all going to cost
um light insurance will cover like most
like it's like 60 ish okay and my
husband or my insurance will cover like
most of it like I had to pay 2500 so it
wasn't that bad but you have to pay for
also for all like the mental health
evaluation all the nutritional classes
all that stuff so how much how much is
all of that Christine how much is all
that do you know
um
ballpark
uh like five two to three thousand okay
maybe is that including your deductible
are you gonna hit your deductible on
this
I yeah yeah I'll hit it before then okay
and then
um have you guys do you know your
expenses week to week of of how much it
costs for you guys to
to live off of that you're going to need
yeah okay it'll be like like 3 500 3 500
total okay perfect yeah and how much are
you guys making like what do you bring
in now per month
um about five okay so this is gonna cost
you go ahead well sorry go ahead oh no I
was gonna say so from what you said the
surgery
um itself is 35 did I get 3 500 from
that and then 2500 a week
5500 for all the surgery stuff 3500 ah
okay so yeah about nine yeah about nine
Grands that you guys are gonna need out
of pockets to make sure you cover all
the yeah the medical stuff and to live
off of yeah because what I would say to
Christina since you guys are on baby
step two I would look at your budget and
say hey what are Necessities yes and if
there's things that you can cut in that
time to limit that nine thousand like
that that 3 500 because I want you to
still be paying on your debt snowball
since you guys have six months to save
for this um that's plenty of time to
save for this and still be working your
debt snowball so we want you to pause it
to make sure you have that cash in the
bank but then I want you to continue to
work the debt snowball
um because I don't want you guys to lose
momentum if it's going to be another six
to eight months because how much debt do
you guys have
um
with school loans I have about 15
000 and then
um in cars we have a truck and a car 30.
okay so I have a question for you since
you've already had this surgery you're
healthy and well is there a way that you
guys can also increase your income
during this time because you said it's
going to be about a six month span that
you have to go through you know all the
red tape before the surgery even happens
so that's it yeah yeah so there's an
opportunity of time there
absolutely yeah my husband uh
construction he picks up side jobs on
the weekends and then I do
um contract nursing contract work okay
um how much do you guys make a year
uh like 90 90 okay
so yeah I mean then there's your plan
the plan is to increase your income as
much as you can during the six months
and pause the baby steps stack up that
money there's gonna be extra you're not
all the money that you stack up is not
going to go on to this medical debt and
as soon as everything's over you're in
the clear throw whatever's left onto the
baby steps and resume the debt snowball
how does that sound does that sound like
it's going to work for you Christine
yeah yes I'm perfect I just wasn't sure
like where to place it yeah I almost I
don't know what would you think of me
yeah okay what did you think about this
what if they saved the 9000 that they
need put it in a separate savings
account and then they just kept on with
the debt snowball
I like that are you nervous medically
something's gonna happen you need some
more cushion because of a major surgery
I'm a little bit nervous about it
um I just want to double check your
deductible is only 2500 is that what you
said I just want to make sure that
you have enough no I no no so my
deductible is three thousand okay but
I'll I'll meet that before the even the
surgery hits because of like other
medical stuff okay there's already so
I'll meet my deductible through for
other medical stuff by like July and
then everything will be covered okay
okay out of pocket like for what I for
my surgery was 2 500 bucks I just feel
like whenever there's a recovery there's
that projected time where it's like
it'll most likely be this much time but
you never know like some people it takes
them a little bit longer so I would just
be very concerned like I would shoot a
little bit past it yeah so that there's
extra I do think that because you're
still working and because you guys have
a nice income there is the ability to do
both at the same time
um
yeah yeah definitely get the nine
thousand dollars saved I think you can
keep going I think this is one of those
things that once you have the money
there and you realize how quickly you
have it it's like well we're just
sitting like we may as well put this
money on debt I don't think that you
have to be paused for a full six months
if that makes sense I agree with that do
you know what I mean so hopefully that
helps out Christine I think that you
guys are in a really great spot you're
thinking through this on all the in all
the right ways just pile up as much
money as you can maybe you sell the
thirty thousand dollar car get out of
the car loan and that that and that
relieves a lot that relieves it
yeah I I like that idea what's the car
worth
uh 20. girl
it might be worth it it might be when
y'all could be out of debt going into
the surgery with money saved an
emergency fund I mean like that would if
you don't really just just did it
Christine you could and if you're going
to be making more than 90 that's what
you're doing some side hustles and stuff
that's right it's the challenge we're
giving you it is the challenge but make
sure you have to to Jade's point though
you know a big life change is happening
that's kind of been the theme I feel
like of this show to have that cushion
because I don't want you going into
medical debt because you don't have any
cash so you know something is coming
save up be conservative above and beyond
maybe the 9000 just to play it safe I
would and then start attacking this debt
and kind of get it out like have this
crazy goal what if we were debt free by
the time the surgery came I and look
anything is possible if they get rid of
that car a lot is possible and speaking
of that that does it for today's show be
sure to join us the next time guys and
remember this when it comes to changing
your life and your money y'all can tell
me that you won't do it but please
please please do not tell me that you
can all things are possible with God on
your side you can do this this is the
Ramsay show hey what's up guys it's Jade
look if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]